not today pal is your new one we had
pajama pants before and so Tom sigura
and Christina P were fans of pajama
pants which was like so weird we had
like 10,000 listeners a week we were
like this tiny little podcast but this
like small and mighty we called them our
panties and like we had so much fun
doing that podcast because we were just
idiots and we and it you know me Rob and
our other cooes CM G are all so
different and but so much love for each
other and it was silly and fun but you
know we weren't making a ton of money
from it and then when I moved to Austin
and then Rob moved to Austin and then
Cass was still in La like you know over
Zoom like you said like it's hard to get
a good it takes
forever and I was going to quit so many
times yeah and you know and just things
kind of clicked here and there and not
that it's like Becca's bunch
you know we have a lot of people out
there who are just really loyal and love
the podcast and help the podcast and
spread great interview too well you're I
know I mean I'm just like I I've learned
I've gotten better because I think in
the beginning like some my friends would
be interviewed and like schwartzen or
Bobby Lee and they'd go don't interrupt
me you're interrupting me i' keep it in
there I go sorry I don't I don't know
what I'm doing Sor right I just was like
so you learn that you learn to listen a
little more um I don't get nervous
anymore I figure you know um we're going
to have a good conversation we're going
to you know figure it out yeah we just
sat down we didn't even you didn't even
say let's go we were just talking no
we've been talking
for a half an hour holy [__] yeah we
don't even have that long to go isn't
that great no but bomber Becca's like
get me out of here um so so so anyway so
when that when PJ pants was kind of like
you know this is just not doing anything
for anyone and it's just the chemistry
is not what it was when we were all
together in a room Tom and Christina
were then expanding their um ymh Studios
Network um their podcast Network and
wanted to bring Rob on and then Rob was
like well I want Jamie to do the show
with me so that's where not today pal
came from and it's you know Rob and I
have a very unique experience like that
we share together which bonds us very
deeply but like has nothing to do with
our relationship today and so not today
pal is about you know him usually just
making me very uncomfortable and me
reacting to it like what does he make
you uncomfortable about what do you get
uncomfortable with I actually don't get
uncomfortable I'm a good sport I think
you know he just likes to they make fun
of
me um yeah they make fun of me a lot
what do they make fun of you
about cutter takes pictures of me
meditating and sends it to him and then
they make fun of me
um they he likes to show me pictures of
me and ex-boyfriends and talk about it